portlandia uh people really love this
show yeah it's a great idea you're
you're you're lampooning the people in
uh in portland oregon yeah obviously and
it seems like it's a very rich area
there's a lot there that you guys can do
yeah everyone's uh tattooed and all
kinds of piercings and a lot of bicycles
um are you uh
a big part of you yeah and you you we
see some of it on portlandia of course
it's a big part of your life on sunday
live is impressions yeah and you come up
with i got to give you a hand you come
up with unusual impressions yeah some
people have the stock impressions they
do but yours i think you're very
creative i don't know if you're working
on anything new oh yeah thanks i'm
working on an impression right now um
it's a a decomposing uh fox you know but
a time lapse photography you ever see
that when you were in school that sort
of they'd show you like these
decomposing it's like it's done over
like uh they shoot a they shoot at a fox
that's dead over like six weeks yeah
yeah yeah so i could do it but i need to
lay down for do you mind if i don't go
yeah all right go ahead
so this is a decomposing time lapse
photography fox yeah can we get ready
very good thank you
thank you very good you're welcome
thank you
i don't know for some reason it's not a
place stinks of dead fox
thanks a lot it's always fox i don't
know why that's the animal they they
chose for they always choose that yeah
um i'm just you are uh you're
you're you're an unusual fellow i'll
give you i've known you for a number of
years and i say that as a compliment
you're very original and i'm very
curious was fred armistead like as a kid
um i you know i i think i was i tried
maybe a little uh i tried hard to be
like be kind of funny and creative but i
think it went the wrong way like when i
was in eighth grade
i wrote this paper about you know the
assignment was for english class what
would you do if it's your last day on
earth to live and i i wrote this paper
that all the other students were kind of
like i'd go visit my family and i'd go
you know walk around the park and and i
uh i wrote this thing that i said i
would just destroy every store on my
street i would smash in windows but i
think as an adolescent i was just being
like
i don't know i just i was just it was
like kind of trying to be funny and i
said i would like light all these places
on fire and i got sent to the school
psychologist
i spent the day of course you did yes i
said it was so uh scary but i was trying
to be funny but uh yeah it just didn't
work out this is uh something you
brought this was uh that you were asked
to write a poem yes
this is an actual poem that you wrote we
have a a a photograph of the real poem
and what does it say here blood
dracula sucks blood and so do i many
insects suck blood even a fly by freddy
armistead
grade look at all of them
[Music]
i think that would yes i also get you
scented yeah i guess this is blood
everywhere yeah yeah well it's more it's
more the ego of your name yeah yeah how
about that yeah yeah i am freddie
you must know who i am